est ce que vous craignez des dérapages
se fait semaine
obstrué la voie publique c'est illégal
ont
dans la foulée des convois de la liberté
le sociaux financement changer la donne
france
nicolas de nouveau si les montagnes sont
astronomiques qui viennent dans nos pays
ça implique un potentiel de
déstabilisation
[Musique]
c'est l'opposition à la vaccination
obligatoire des camionneurs
transfrontalier qui râlent ils convoient
même si une forte majorité des
camionneurs sont vaccinés dans la manif
des monsieur madame toutlemonde qui
expriment leur ras-le-bol des mesures
sanitaires
jusque là c'est la liberté d'expression
en marche une manifestation et les
inconvénients qui doivent être supportés
par la population car des groupes
décident de manifester ses protégés par
la liberté d'expression en droit 4 la
situation s'enlise la police n'arrive
pas à freiner le ravitaillement et les
manifestants disent qu'ils sont là pour
rester
un technologie dans le financement
participatif actuellement permet que ce
financement là se distribue très
rapidement et peut passer un peu sous le
radar des gouvernements bientôt le grand
public découvre l'ampleur de leur trésor
de guerre tamara leach qui deviendra
l'une des figures de proue du mouvement
a déjà reçu un million des 10 millions
de dollars recueillis en deux semaines
sur la plateforme goff admis résultat
ils ont de l'essence du pain et des jeux
en abondance et de l'amour
je veux dire aussi on est dans l'amour
on est dans la festivité l'amour c'est
l'antithèse de ce que prend pas de king
l'un des organisateurs clo
aux états unis il donne des entrevues à
titre de responsable du convoi
et
qui nourrit ses centaines de milliers
d'abonnés depuis plusieurs années de
désinformation et de racisme
c'est une façon de présenter des idées
qui habituellement sont pas acceptables
c'est un événement festif et familial
est l'objectif du mouvement festif et
familial ce n'était pas juste d'être
festif et familial c'était de renverser
le gouvernement
vertigo nos
milieux
[Musique]
où
le problème dans le contexte de ce qui
s'est passé avec le convoi des
camionneurs c'est qu'ils ont choisi de
bloquer des artères de bloquer des ponts
ou d'occuper une ville comme 1 3 ce
n'est pas protégé par la définition
retenue en droit canadien de la
manifestation
américain
[Musique]
quelques jours après le début du convoi
go fans me coupe les ponts avec les
organisateurs en raison d'incidents
violents et d'activités criminelles
la plateforme rembourse les donateurs
mais la plateforme américaine gifts and
go prend le relais et six fondateurs
voit ce qui se passe au canada d'un tout
autre oeil
[Musique]
ils ont accepté de nous rencontrer à
nashville dans un congrès des médias
chrétiens c'est la première fois qu'ils
accordent une entrevue à un média
d'information canadien
un espoir inclusif y compris pour des
individus qui ont participé à l'assaut
du capitole 6 janvier 2021 washington
games and go à héberger leurs collectes
pour assurer leur défense idem pour des
membres des pros de buzz une milice
d'extrême droite maintenant classés
comme terroristes au canada
[Applaudissements]
non
définitive cenco a maintenu la campagne
pour le convoi même après que la
manifestation a été déclaré illégal et
après l'adoption de la loi sur les
mesures d'urgence
ici au congrès des médias chrétiens on
est en guerre contre les géants du web
sur fond de polarisation politique
gougaud
amazon facebook
twitter qu'aux fans mais dans l'univers
de la droite chrétienne ceux ci sont des
ennemis de leur valeur il faut se sortir
de ces plateformes
des intégristes religieux
la démocratie libérale il déteste ça
parce que la démocratie libérale mais
les droits humains ou déçus des droits
du
la nouvelle réalité du financement
participatif c'est que se cache derrière
dans le cas de certains groupes
fondamentalistes religieux des agendas
politiques
sur ses 13 millions $ récoltés pour le
convoi des camionneurs au canada près de
40 % vient des états unis selon gibson
go ce qui est nouveau c'est les
montagnes sont astronomiques qui
viennent d'un autre pays la campagne
freedom convoy 2022 sur la plateforme
gifts and go était au profit d'un
organisme sans but lucratif
enregistré le 30 janvier il y à sept
administrateurs dont à marly et chris
barber qui sont maintenant accusés
d'incitation à commettre des méfaits une
autre campagne adopte traqueur a
recueilli 800 mille dollars les fonds
des deux campagnes sont toujours gelés
par une ordonnance de la cour de
l'ontario à partir du moment où on peut
faire les transferts de d'autres pays
par des plateformes comme games and go
tout est passé puis la loi canadienne
s'applique pas quand ça vient d'un autre
pays nécessairement donc si difficile de
bloquer ce depuis la fin de l'occupation
les députés se penchent sur ce problème
dans le cadre d'un comité parlementaire
suis vice présidente du comité permanent
de la sécurité publique et nationale
on étudie le convoi des camionneurs
l'ingérence étrangère dans le
financement ce qu'on voit à l'heure
alors on essaie d'avoir des réponses à
ces questions là les fondateurs de
gibson go ont témoigné devant les
députés au début du mois
donc pour
certains députés ghz 16 go est le
parfait exemple de ce qu une loi devrait
empêcher
on était tous abasourdis de regarder ce
témoignage là et de voir des gens qui se
disent non équitable
nous on voyait tu avais des mouvements
extrémistes qui était lié à tout ça
oui oui
quand on dit qu'on veut financer le klu
klux klan un organisme qui est
ouvertement raciste j'appelle pas ça est
neutre
et fort une conception très américaine
de la liberté d'expression qui sortent
de très très peu de limites là dessus la
liberté d'expression aux états unis plat
manière d'agir et de faire parler son
argent dans la sphère politique en place
beaucoup plus grande en droit américain
qu en droit canadien qui acceptent des
limites plus importante à la capacité de
ces groupes le puissant d'intervenir
dans des campagnes politiques dans des
mouvements partis mais chez gibson go la
liberté a ses limites on ne permettrait
pas ce sous financement pour contester
les lois américaines anti avortement
non
feinte
l'internationalisation de ses
plateformes l'a fait en sorte justement
que comme ce sont des particuliers
peuvent même se coller aux régimes
politiques qui leur convient donc
comment on fait pour encadrer pour
s'assurer que personne s'ingèrent dans
nos espaces de debug est ce que vous
comptez sur la bonne foi des placements
de sociaux financement de ces gèrent
eux-mêmes ou est ce que c'est le travail
du gouvernement d'aller s'ingérer là
dedans et de rides jacob ont d'abord
promis de rembourser les millions
recueillis pour le convoi
ils ont affirmé cette semaine qu'ils ont
remboursé environ 9 millions de dollars
mais il demeure évasif sur le sol de 4
millions le suspense perdure sur ce
qu'il adviendra d'une partie des
millions du convoi
[Musique]